did you know that the world's richest
man just 50 years ago was completely
Anonymous and no one knew his name this
is a wild story Daniel Ludwig was born
in 1897 in Michigan he started his
career in his teenage years literally
moving molasses and lumber all around
the Great Lakes area then Ludwig hit a
gold mine he figured out how to finance
the building of massive ships using
other people's money and other people's
credit over the coming two or three
decades Ludwig ended up owning over 60
of the world's largest vessels and he
became the world's largest shipper but
Daniel Ludwig's ambition knew absolutely
no bounds by the end Daniel owned over
200 companies in 50 different countries
and he had a 4.5 billion dollar net
worth but the craziest part is that no
one knew who Daniel Ludwig was he
completely shunned the media and he
avoided any use of his name with
companies or projects that he was
involved in imagine if that happened
today